smiles oh you know it was hot let me see
let me see
she's from Murrieta California let me
see
is that the long-haired one she's okay
no she's she's okay she's uh she's a so
what you wait what's the what's the
thing of that what are you judging yeah
no it's great
okay someone else a poor lucky oh really
what is the cosmetologist a makeup
artist yeah yeah it's hard to get into
makeup yeah yeah I think they make a
really good living especially if you
work in LA living if the ones that do
well do well and everybody else not
doing well yeah cuz you have to like get
with an agency and like a lot of like
you know the good jobs are there they're
not even paying people they're just
doing it for the resume oh really so I
think porn makeup artists like make a
lot more than like your average makeup
art well do they wait before making
paint what they get paid more than like
like a movie a makeup artist no like not
a movie makeup artist cuz I I think like
the makeup artists that are working or
me I it's kind of like acting I think
the ones who are known or making money
and everyone else is not you have an
agent - right I don't know how it works
yeah mark yeah I like him yeah yeah so
what does he take 10% is that like
normal
oh he takes 10% of all my money great I
mean that's what agent what are you
family
everything no kidding but actually now
that I'm with wicked he doesn't get
anything why because you've got that
deal obviously well and also um yeah
basically like it once you're under
contract it's like because he's not
working for me you know yeah but he got
de need not get you the wicked thing not
directly mm-hmm also he's my friend
yeah well you know what happened to me
right I didn't have an agent no I was
but back when I got that TV I didn't
have an agent right so I couldn't get a
never get that job because of my manager
who I'm still with right so she she had
a client who was a producer on that
Lorne Dombrowski so I got the audition
through Lauren and then what happened
was the day
tested for the show which you know you
go to the network and you audition for
the network girls called me and they
said hey we're gonna go see your
contract I go who the [ __ ] are you there
were the grocery agency I go yeah but
what's the new what like yeah and then
my manager goes you have to sign with
them because if you sign with them if
you sign with them then they're gonna
get your movies and all this other stuff
not good too
so um I signed with them they did one
day of negotiating they got eight years
of ten ten percent of my money every
week for doing one day of work they
didn't start with you what they didn't
even start with you know they showed up
the day I got the [ __ ] show yeah and
so what I left I left can't really do
much airman how long was that contract
for why I mean they got eight years of
madtv's no matter what yeah no matter
what right because they did the
negotiation right right so they made
thousands do they get you other work I
mean I got Harold and Kumar but it's all
yeah but I got that one scene like who
gives a [ __ ]
yeah buddy everyone knows who knows yeah
but I'm just saying though that like did
they do that or was it because I was on
MADtv and because I was alright on their
radar
did they get a call like yeah we heard
you represent Bobby Lee yeah like I
wasn't I never even went inside the
building ever before oh wow at least
with CAA they they have meetings with me
they give me coffee
yeah they show me like paperwork like
this is what we're tracking we're trying
to do for you and they're like the best
right yeah but you don't want they all
the same thing I mean I love my guys but
I really do I love my guys but they all
want to talk about so before this
[Music]